this is I think the Health crisis of our
time dementia we're a country of 60
million people and there will soon be
one million people with dementia are you
hopeful this is a disease that we can
treat the battle against these diseases
is like a marathon Race you know it's a
26 mile race and if you look at cancer
we're probably in mile you know 18 or 19
lots of cancers we now know how to treat
and prevent but we've still got
somewhere to go I think with Alzheimer's
we're in like mile nine or ten we will
finish this race we will get it done but
we've got a long way to go the great
about medical research is when you get
one small breakthrough you then get a
huge amount of enthusiasm and there are
over 140 drugs in trial so I'm hopeful
but there still needs to be government
action philanthropy as well as the
pharmaceutical companies coming in as
well although there is a lot of Hope for
people with with Alzheimer's at the
moment arguably they're being failed by
a social care system and that's having a
knock-on impact on our Healthcare
Service as well do we need to really
focus on fixing social care crisis yes I
think there are two parts to this
there's one part which is how do you
make the NHS and social Care Systems
work better together there's then a
second problem which is the cost of
long-term care that is what the dill not
cap so-called the cap on care costs
which you know my government
commissioned and looked at but didn't
Implement that's what it's there to deal
with I still want us to do that the
current Chancellor is facing exactly
this dilemma at the moment whether to
honor that cap or not and there's a
tough spending review coming up what
would you say well first of all it's
good that we have a chancellor who spent
five years as health secretary is very
aware of these issues he's got his very
difficult job to do I just think as he
looks at this cap I would say look again
at the issue of is there some way of
providing some sort of backstop
insurance so that you don't have to sell
your home to pay for care that might be
the answer but
um that's for the government to decide